joe flacco had been looking for work and
he has now
found it kind of a surprise given his
health condition a serious neck injury
that some thought would prevent him from
passing a physical at any time before
the 2021 or 2020 season began or 2021
for that matter flacco has a gig now on
the depth chart with the new york jets
behind sam darnold it's a 1.5 million
dollar base deal with a maximum value of
4.5 million that requires him probably
to play and play well to make that kind
of money this is a guy who
not all that long ago in the grand
scheme of things with the highest paid
player in league history taking what he
can get to continue his career devante
freeman
maybe you should follow joe flacci's
lead because there is a point where you
just have to take what you can get
taking the 1.5 million he'll be the guy
behind sam darnold assuming flacco is
healthy and look when you consider the
revolving door of crap the jets had last
year after darnold got mono and how it
derailed their season it makes sense to
have a backup that you believe can at
least allow you to be somewhat
competitive in games that darnold may
not be able to play chris yeah that's
exactly right you know mike i mean first
off sam darnold hasn't played a complete
season yet in his first two years had
the mono issue last year had the hurt
foot his rookie year this is a big year
for the new york jets and especially
adam gase and the coaching staff you
know so to where i love the signing is
joe flacco's a he's a perfect backup
he's not going to be threatening in any
shape way or form to a guy like sam
darnold so you're good there right and
you know to second that with the point
of uh again if a sam darnold did miss
miss a few games you know i thought the
jets all off season were to make taking
and i brought this up on my podcast a
few times just as far as taking a big
risk if sam darnold did get hurt and wow
you're going to go with david fails as
your backup quarterback to me that would
have kind of been career suicide for
adam gase and company if they got to
that i would have just said well sam
donald's hurt you're gonna lose your
games now and you know most likely
you're gonna get fired at the end of the
season joe flacco yeah he's not going to
come in and like set the world on fire
but
he certainly
uh can still throw the football and
understands how to run an offense and do
those type of things so joe douglas i i
just again i think it was a great sign
and of course he's got history with joe
flacco because he's been in baltimore
and all that too so that made a lot of
sense
boy and how the worm has turned from
flacco's time in baltimore he had that
team over a barrel after super bowl
prize seven he did the ultimate all-in
bet on himself rejected the offer that
the ravens made on a second contract in
august of 2012 led the team to the super
bowl won the mvp award and ultimately
leveraged one at the time was a record
contract and the cap numbers were so
back loaded that after three years they
had to redo the deal and by then he
didn't deserve to be the highest paid
player in football but his circumstances
under his contract allowed him to yet
again
be the highest paid player and he cashed
plenty of those checks from the ravens
all in the aftermath of super bowl 47
got paid well last year by the broncos
after he was traded there by baltimore
but now he takes what he can get because
of that that neck injury chris and i
really thought that neck injury was
something that was going to keep him
from signing with anyone but for 1.5
million
it's a very limited downside for the
jets and it gives them the protection
that they didn't have that's the key
it's only one and a half million dollars
teams
waste far more than that all the time
this is the most important position on
the field they had no backup that they
clearly felt strongly enough about right
with so you roll the dice and it's not
much of a price to pay to take the
chance that maybe you end up getting a
guy who can help make the difference
between a season of promise and a season
of disaster
right yeah exactly right you know and
again it's it's really you know mike i
don't know it's rare to see a
quarterback with
you know this type of career still want
to play at this point of his career for
that little of money i mean really you
know joe flacco seems like he still
wants to go he's really he's from new
jersey i'm sure that was for a little
bit part of like the connection or maybe
maybe making that to want to happen but
yeah i think ultimately this was the
right move for the new york jets you
know we mentioned david's fails they
drafted you know james morgan uh in the
fourth round of the draft he's got a lot
of talent but is raw and a little bit of
a gunslinger and not the type of guy as
a rookie that you're gonna go we want
him to be the backup in week five and
he'll come in if sam darnold gets gets
banged up and he'll run the offense no i
don't think he'll be ready for that kid
might have a chance for a bright future
but they needed a guy that could come in
right now
and a guy like joe flacco to your point
mike could be the difference between you
going ten and six and seven and seven
and nine or or you know something like
that he could be worth a win or two if
you play the right way when he's in the
game if sam darnold does get a high
ankle sprain in the middle of the season
or whatever that may be and then of
course that would save a guy like adam
gases uh coaching you know career in new
york and everything else so really good
signing by them and honestly i'm a
little surprised joe flacco wanted to do
it and still wanted to play i can't lie
about that
you make an excellent point though as it
relates to flacco's willingness to take
whatever he can get because guys that
have made that kind of money that have
had that status as franchise quarterback
it is a significant mental adjustment to
go
back to being a backup or you were never
a backup joe flacco entered the league i
remember back in 2007
the ravens desperately wanted to go with
troy smith to be their starter because
they were concerned about the offensive
line they were concerned about flacco's
ability to protect himself 2008 excuse
me it was right
troy smith got tonsillitis during the
preseason and flacco got a chance to
play and that satisfied the ravens that
flacco was good to go so he was the
starter from day one he's never been
that backup i mean this is a slap in the
face when you consider a guy's overall
status
but you know what he loves football and
he wants to play and he wants to be
around the game and he's not ready to
walk away so he's willing to take
a fraction of what he made i mean this
is a guy who was making north of 20
million a year and now he's gonna make
1.5 as a base proposition and if all
things go well for the jets he'll only
make 1.5 million because he won't play
he won't have a chance to make that
extra 3 million on top of 1.5 because
it'll be sam darnold getting it done so
it really is surprising to me
that
a franchise quarterback who was one of
the highest paid players in the game and
at times the highest-paid player in
league history would say i'll take
whatever i can get to keep going because
i can't imagine peyton manning ever
doing that he didn't right i can't
imagine tom brady ever doing that i
can't imagine any of the all-time great
quarterbacks i can't imagine aaron
rodgers saying yeah i'm willing to be
someone's backup i just want to continue
to be in the nfl i can't imagine anyone
doing it and i think it's a great point
that flacco and i think this is the
ultimate litmus test on how much a guy
loves the game if you're willing to
humble yourself and do it you you truly
love it chris
yeah that's right he's a humble guy too
you know joe flacco is going to be no
distraction he'll be a great like
backup guy for sam donald as far as you
know being able to teach sam darnold
some tricks and some things that you
know sam darling hasn't been around a
big time quality backup like that that's
going to be cool you know he's certainly
going to have something there let alone
flacco's not going to be looking to make
a controversy or anything like that you
know the other thing too with flacco the
last two years he's been a very
supportive guy to two young quarterbacks
we saw him cheering on drew locke last
year when he was not in uniform on the
denver sidelines the year before that he
was really supportive of lamar jackson
and even when the ravens had a few games
of like not looking good on offense
people tried to start that oh joe do you
think you deserve to be back in there
and maybe start as a quarterback he
squashed it he did the right thing by
the team right all the way and you know
again this is this is to me joe flacco
this is what made him a really good
quarterback on a team that had a lot of
personalities and why he could fit in in
baltimore with the teeth you know ed
reed and ray lewis who unlike most teams
we're the leader of the team it's
usually the quarterback and the
quarterback's that guy but in baltimore
you knew they they marched to a
different band there with that group of
guys and he was great that way and i
think you know for a lot of reasons he's
a little bit underrated with his whole
career because he was willing to take
that back seat in that leadership
position there in baltimore
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports